okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q
a for kids and others by the way there's
a
increasing library of recordings of this
from the past
year and a half or so that are on the
web
including a cool feature courtesy of our
wolfram language
video processing capabilities which is
word clouds for the things i've been
talking about here
and so it might actually be possible to
find
things about topics you're interested in
and also we're turning these things into
podcasts i think thematic podcasts at
some point
so again if you're interested place to
find things
all right let's see we have a bunch of
questions that were left over from last
time
[Music]
and let's see
there's a question here from d0 what is
the scientific method
boy that's a complicated thing
particularly in these years
um so
you know the origin of the term
scientific method comes from people like
francis bacon back in the
early 1600s maybe i think
there was sort of a question of if
you're going to figure out how the world
works how are you supposed to do it
and the you know prevailing wisdom
back in antiquity in the time of the
babylonians the ancient greeks all this
kind of thing was
to figure out how the world works just
think about it
in other words if you want to know why
is there gravity pulling stuff
to the uh pulling stuff down
well you think about it and there's this
idea
that things tend to get pulled towards
the center of the earth let's say
just because they do so to speak and
people would imagine
that things should somehow make sense
that if one thing happens
you can understand that that causes
something else to happen just as a
matter of kind of logical necessity
if this works this way then this was
worked this way then that must work that
way
and so on and so sort of the the first
concept was you can just by pure thought
figure out
how the world works and you know plants
grow up
this way because and then pure thought
this is how it works
well then
i think people there were
often quite wacky theories for things
and
people ended up developing like a a
common theory that i'm
i'm um um
[Music]
there were theories about you know how
was disease spread there was theories
about the fact for example for a long
time people believed that
things like maggots you know little bug
critters
would spontaneously arise in any lump of
mud
that even if there weren't any before
the mud would somehow spontaneously
create life
a lot of things like that that people
believed
and then people came along and said
you know why do you believe that and and
for example there were other things
where well we believe it because it was
written down
in the bible some other sacred book
somewhere
you know that somebody said this is how
the world works
it's written down to be this way and
people said well why is that true
and that that was kind of the the origin
i think of people
wanting to come up with sort of a
a a systematic procedure for finding out
what's actually true about the world and
what's not
another thing that came up must have
been in the
12 to 1400s i think was the thing called
occam's razor
principle uh which is kind of the
following thing if you're going to try
to explain something
there might be an easy explanation like
well where did the maggots come from for
in in the mud well it's because there
were already maggot eggs in the mud or
something
uh that's a simple explanation the more
complicated explanation is
well there's this spontaneous process
where you know first the mud turns into
this and then it turns into that and
pretty soon
you've recapitulated the history of
evolution and you've got a maggot
right and and that's a much more
complicated theory and the idea of
arkham's raza
was that the theory that is
more likely to be right is the one that
has the fewer extra pieces that have to
be added into it
it's an interesting question to what
extent that principle
really works when we're looking at
different areas of science
in in some areas it works better than
others um
in uh for example in biology it often
doesn't work that well
because actually things are complicated
because of the sort of detailed history
of biological evolution and so on
anyway back to sort of the the origins
of the scientific method
then there kind of was this idea well
just do an experiment you know make up a
hypothesis
do an experiment see if it's true
and that in a sense is a
uh seems like a cleaner kind of
intellectual workflow
of uh you know if you want to know
whether in fact um
i don't know all kinds of terrible
experiments people
all kinds of crazy experiments people
did like another experiment for some
reason i'm reminded of
was the if you raise a child super bad
idea
raise a child without any human
interaction without ever hearing a
language
what language will they start off
speaking that was a a crazy
experiment supposedly done at some point
and and the claim was that they'd start
off speaking i don't remember which
language
i don't remember greek maybe i've
forgotten but but um
uh of course that experiment was super
hard to do but that's at least
a a systematic experiment you know you
can imagine doing the experiment
or you can imagine saying let me set
this thing up um in such a way that i
can
have a hypothesis about what's going to
happen i do the experiment
i see whether the result is is correct
or not
and then uh
that that workflow presupposes various
things for example
it presupposes the idea that you can
actually do the experiment
there are plenty of experiments we can't
do for example in economics let's say
there are plenty of things which just
aren't experiments you can do not for
reasons
of or would mess up the world if you did
it but just because
you can't separate things out enough to
be able to do that as an independent
experiment
there are plenty of other cases where
you can't do that experiment let's say
it's a
i don't know you could imagine the
question you know is it really bad to
have human clones
well you know one could imagine an
experiment to do that but
one shouldn't do it so to speak for
completely for other reasons
um it's uh so you know there are
experiments that are
that are just not ethically reasonable
to do there are experiments you can't do
because you can't separate the system
well enough
from the rest of the world to be able to
do that as a separate experiment
and there are things like you could say
well
let's um uh you know there are things
where you just can't do it because
it you know you need to send a
spacecraft to wherever
to do this and we just can't do that
right now
um lots of other kinds of kinds of
issues like that
but um uh the question
of um um
the uh um
yeah so so um uh so so then
as this th this idea is you
you set up an experiment you make a
hypothesis you do the experiment
then you find out whether your
hypothesis is true or not
and one of the things that that that's a
good idea in principle
in practice it it really often doesn't
work that easily
another thing that people say is well if
you have a hypothesis
there's this big kind of test you know
is it a falsifiable hypothesis
is there some experiment you could do
where if the experiment came out the
wrong way
you'd say my hypothesis is false
well that's a tricky business let's say
let's say that you are it depends what
kind of a thing
you are setting up like for example
let's take a classic example
is the theory of natural selection uh
kind of basically
darwinism darwin's theory of evolution
by natural selection
what would be an experiment that we
could do that would show that that
theory isn't true well
it's tricky because there are
for example one thing you might try to
do is say
well it doesn't matter um
like for example if it's the case that
the things that happen during the
lifetime of an organism
are passed down to its children that
would be a little bit
kind of tweaking the theory of natural
selection
um although not completely blowing it up
but the point is that the theory of
natural selection is more a framework
for thinking about things than it is a
pure
kind of uh theory where you say it might
be this way it might be that way
i mean another good example is what
would it take
if you say calculus is calculus
a falsifiable theory well no it's just a
mathematical method for doing things
you can then ask is it useful does it
actually describe how the world works
well it might describe how one part of
the world works doesn't describe how
another part of the world works
that doesn't mean calculus is wrong so
to speak
it means calculus is useful for this
thing it's not useful for that thing and
so on
so then the other thing that can happen
is
people can say sort of the scientific
method ends up being
experiment will decide everything you
you make a hypothesis
that's a sort of theory then you do an
experiment if the experiment doesn't
come out the way that your hypothesis
said
then your theory must be wrong the
history of science does not support
that kind of cut and dried workflow
because
often it's the case that there is a
theory
maybe it's a very clean simple theory
but to figure out what its consequences
are for particular experiments is quite
difficult
and goes far beyond that original clean
theory
classic example of this is uh newton's
theory of gravity the inverse square law
where newton tried to use that to
compute the motion of the moon
and got it wrong and it took another
hundred years before people had managed
to do
sort of the detailed work to go from
newton's sort of clean
theory of uh the inverse square law
to an actual computation with all the
detailed mathematics and so on
of the motion of the moon so there's
sort of a there's the theory
which is the thing you are sort of
targeting
as the piece of basic science then
there's kind of the development that
gets you to the actual thing
about which you can do an experiment
then there's the experiment itself
things go wrong in experiments
particularly when it's an experiment
that's never been done before
particularly when it's an experiment
that says does this happen or not
sometimes the or not means oh we didn't
see anything
well maybe you didn't see anything
because you weren't looking in the quite
the right way in your experiment
maybe the way it worked was a little
different than you expected so you
didn't see anything
even though if you looked at it
correctly you would see it
so that can be quite quite tricky as
well
then the next kind of worms is
the question of well how big is the
effect
you say it should be the case that
i don't know people who eat more carrots
will live longer or something or who
will do this or that and you say
well how big is that effect you know
you'd say there is an effect
people who do this will do that um
but it's not going to happen all the
time
that this happens or that happens or you
know in
in modern times uh you know people who
have this vaccine
will be protected from this virus or
will get the following side effect
these things can happen the question is
how often do they happen
and so then you you go into the huge and
very messy area
of things which aren't sort of slam dunk
this has to happen this doesn't happen
but sort of happens sometimes but don't
always happen
so for example in physics there are some
experiments
uh in classical physics particularly
where it's like
it either happens or it doesn't you can
measure the thing
it's either doing this or it isn't doing
this and you can fairly cleanly see
sort of what whether the theory is
supported or not
when it comes to things close to life
sciences and biology and so on
it tends to be the case that nothing or
very little
happens always it's usually well it
often happens that this or that occurs
why is that well it's because biological
systems are very complicated
and it's like you might say well all
rats that ate more carrots did better in
the maze
very unlikely to be true it's you know
it'll be
particular rats that have particular
genetics
or particular rats that had been exposed
to these in
this environment before or particular
rats that had eaten these things before
there are many details of the
characteristics of the rat
so to speak that can affect the outcome
of that experiment
or maybe just the rats you know the rat
wasn't feeling very
well that day for reasons that were just
completely outside of the experiment
that you were sort of controlling
so particularly in the biological
sciences there's an awful lot
of well does it happen or not well it
happens a bit
some of the time but not all the time
same is true
in areas of physics that involve uh for
example
quantum mechanics where everything is is
couched in terms of probabilities of
will this happen with certain
probability or not
or certain other areas of physics like
statistical physics same kinds of things
happen
so so then you're sort of thrown into
well is this a real effect or not
and then you're thrown into the question
of well yes we see
some rats that do much better in the
maze and some rats that don't
okay is that a significant effect or not
so this leads you into the whole area of
statistical analysis
and there's a lot that was developed
particularly in the 1930s
for testing sort of the significance of
some statistical result
if you have 20 rats and five of them did
really well
is that significant or not and
the i have to say that in my own
experiences in science
and in looking at experiments both
experiments in
in sort of actual physical experiments
and computer experiments and things
basically my attitude is always if
you can't get enough data that the
effect you're looking for is visually
obvious
in the right kind of information
visualization it's not a real effect
and that in modern times as it's become
in many areas many places easier and
easier to get large amounts of data
using automated data taking and things
like this that's a pretty reasonable
approach just get so much data
that you plot the graph and there are
two big
clusters of points and it's really
visually obvious that there's an effect
as soon as it's like well you can kind
of see there's an effect by doing fancy
statistics
my attitude is that's a very
fragile situation and and very
very sort of fraught with peril but
there's been a tradition from the 1930s
on
to use kind of methods from statistics
to
kind of tease out smaller effects
often in medical testing this is sort of
the only thing you can do because there
are
so many uh sort of features of different
well you gave this drug to this group of
people and that group of people
and you know a few people got really
well on this we're using this drug and a
few people had nasty side effects and
most people didn't make much difference
when you've got those small effects you
kind of don't have a choice but to try
and
sort of dive into statistical analysis
so maybe i can say a little bit about
how that statistical analysis works so
one of the questions is
if you see 5 out of 20 rats or something
uh have show some effect
is that significant and um
there's a whole set of approaches to
that question
uh often in terms of p values confidence
intervals
a bunch of similarly uh similar concepts
with somewhat different names but let me
try and explain
at least one of these so
the question is let's say you're
asking um
do the rats run through the maze
more quickly that's not perhaps the best
formulation
[Music]
um
let's say uh
well okay let's say let's let's ask a
question
about um um
did yeah is
is the rate of side effects from a
vaccine
kind of is it
notable or is it not so let's say you
know
that of a thousand people who got this
vaccine
five developed some problem okay then
you have to ask
well how many would have developed that
problem if you
didn't give them the vaccine and so then
you have to ask what's the rate of
people developing that problem
ordinarily well let's say based on the
ordinary rate
three would have developed developed
that problem in the period of time that
you're looking at for this vaccine
okay now obviously you can when it's
something like vaccine response you can
there's a little bit more detail because
you know the specific day the person got
the vaccine and so
you can you can tease out a little bit
more information there but assuming you
didn't know that
and assuming it's just during this
two-week period let's say
how many people ordinarily get such and
such a thing going on
well so let's say that with a vaccine it
was five without the vaccine it was
three
is that significant or not so then you
get into this whole
question of what's the distribution what
what's the
what what is the probability that you
end up with uh
three versus five because those numbers
are small enough
that it is really
uh that it's not obvious what's going on
so let me give you an example
let's say you toss a coin you have
chance 50 chance it will come up heads
50 chance will come up tails
let's say that you toss the coin five
times and it's heads every time
okay what do you conclude from that do
you conclude that
oh it just happened that way or do you
conclude
oh this is a a a kind of a trick
coin where it's always going to come up
heads that's what you're having to
address with this
and unfortunately there is in the end
no great way to kind of
answer that question in other words
there's no great way to go back
from data and say you know is this
surprising or not
because to know if it's surprising you
have to have a model for what should
have happened
but often the only way you have a model
for what should have happened is to look
at the data itself
and what tends to happen particularly in
things like medical research
is that people revert to certain sort of
standardized models
the most common is gaussian or normal
distributions
it's assuming that most things the
probability that you have a certain
value
is distributed according to a bell curve
so for example it is true
at least it's claimed to be dry i have
to admit i've never really checked this
myself
that human heights are roughly normal
distributed
that means there is a an average height
you know i have to say
even as i'm saying this to you guys i
just
this can't possibly be quite right but
it's certainly what's claimed
um you know there's an average height
whatever it is five foot eight or
something in the us maybe
and there's a a distribution of people
so there'll be somebody who's seven feet
tall
there'll be somebody who's four feet
tall and but the chance that you find a
seven foot tall person is quite low
and the peak of the distribution is
let's say around five foot eight or
something
and um and then there's a a certain uh
width of the distribution
that is the the chance that you find
somebody with a certain height
and so for example in in the particular
distribution
the um the circle one standard deviation
uh is 68 of of uh
of people would be within one standard
deviation of the
of the average height uh you can work
out standard deviation
just mathematically by by looking at the
uh
expected value of the of the the
difference from the mean
the square of the difference from the
mean um
but uh in any case so the uh
the thing that tends to get done is to
assume
everything is gaussian distributed and
if you assume everything is gaussian
distributed
then yes you can work out the
probability that you find an eight foot
tall person or something
um because it's just given by this this
uh this probability distribution that
you've assumed
unfortunately it actually isn't true
that everything is gaussian distributed
for example
even if it's the case that human heights
are gas and distributed which i
somewhat doubt actually um it must
depend on what population you're in
there are certainly parts of the world
where people are
on average taller than others and so on
um
but uh the um in any case
human weights for example i know are not
gaussian distributed they
follow a thing called the log normal
distribution and if you look at
different kinds of biological
phenomena different biological features
you'll find some are gaussian
distributed but some are not
for example if you look at levels of
different kinds of chemicals in your
blood
you'll find that some are pretty
gaussian distributed
but others have kind of skewed
distributions some have very very
distorted distributions because they're
like um
hormones where the response of the body
is exponential to the
the um amount of hormone and so that
that means that
there's really a very different
distribution then there's the question
of
how do we even know what the
distribution is for some of these things
in other words in order to find the
distribution we have to have sampled at
random
some population but how exactly was that
done so a typical way that that can go
horribly wrong
is the following thing so let's say
you're doing medical tests
and you say well we're going to find out
what this distribution is like
for our particular population that come
to our particular hospital
by uh just looking at what all the
results of the tests at that particular
hospital are well the problem is
that hospital might be one where oh
you know for whatever reason they have
the policy that everybody who comes in
gets their blood pressure measured it's
a pretty typical thing but let's say
everybody who comes in gets their
complete blood count uh done and
so but then another hospital might have
the policy
oh we're really trying to save money on
this we're only going to do
a complete blood count for people who
have this kind of problem
and so that means that the distribution
for that second hospital because of some
detail about oh they only chose to have
these tests done in this particular case
that will end up being distorted
relative to the one where
people were just oh everybody who comes
in gets this done
of course even even the the everybody
who comes into the hospital gets this
done
doesn't give you the typical
distribution for the population
because people aren't just typically
going into the hospital for fun they're
going in because there's something
wrong and so this whole question about
how these statistics work
in sort of the real world where you're
taking different kinds of samples and so
on
it's really complicated for medical
tests in particular
there tends to be a lot of complicated
essentially gaming
that ends up happening because if you're
testing a drug you spent
you just spent hundreds of millions of
dollars billion dollars
developing this drug and you're trying
to see
is this drug effective for somebody well
you definitely want to pick
people to test it on but it's more
likely that it's going to be effective
and that's a good thing to do because
otherwise you throw the drug out because
let's say
let's say it's spectacularly effective
one out of 100 times
that's still a useful drug of course if
it gives some nasty side effect
you know 20 out of 100 times then well
then that's a complicated question
what you do about it but um uh
so you know you don't want it you want
to pick a population where it's more
likely the drug is going to work
otherwise you'll just throw away you
know good stuff
but that can be quite uh there's quite a
lot of gaming that can go on
in terms of how you know how that
population is picked and so on the sort
of recruitment of people for clinical
trials
is always a complicated issue now you
know you can ask
about um things like oh i don't know how
big is the effect
this whole question like like you know
does a vaccine produce
more of this side effect than you would
expect sometimes it'll be
totally obvious i mean it's by such a
large factor
that i mean for example with with some
of the things with with covet and some
of these vaccines
there are there are medical effects
where they just are never seen
in any other place it's like there is no
background rate
because this collection of symptoms is
just never seen so you can kind of
reasonably assume that it came from
the new thing that was being done but
there are other things you can do i mean
the
the trick is always to find kind of uh
things you can look at that are
independent of assumptions that you make
about a model like for example
uh someone pointed out to me that with
with these uh vaccine side effects one
of the things you can do
is take the ratio of the side effects
from uh people
who've got different vaccines it's not
perfect because there's slightly
different
populations that got different vaccines
in different places but it's a pretty
good approximation and there are
then some some big effects that you see
there and those are probably fairly
robust
and don't depend much on assumptions
about you know what was the background
rate of this what was the background
rate of that
what's the chance that this could happen
just purely
randomly without there being a real
effect but anyway coming back to sort of
what does this mean about the scientific
method
people have this idea oh we'll do oh
let me mention another thing about
medical tests that's that's relevant
the so-called the notion of a
double-blind medical test
so one of the issues is you tell
somebody
this little pill is going to make you
better
they take the pill they get better
sometimes it matters whether people
think they're going to get better
really affects whether they get better
we don't completely understand all the
mechanisms by which that works but it's
clear
the brain has more to say about things
like our immune systems
than we might have imagined and you know
people who
are sort of more upbeat about about
things
will often do better so in other words
just by the very
idea that you're given this pill and
you're told this is going to make you
better
that will tip the scales on whether you
get better
independent of whether that pill is
what's making you better
so that effect was observed quite a bit
in medical tests
and so then this idea was invented of
double-blind
testing where basically you have two
arms to the
to the sometimes more but but in first
approximation two arms
to your tests you have people who are
given pills
that really have medicine in them and
people who are giving pills that are
just don't have any medicine at all in
them
and um that are just you know just pure
sugar pills or something
so the the that's the so-called placebo
arm
of the test so there's the the sort of
active almond as the placebo arm
and um the idea is what you do then
is you compare the results from people
who got
the the real medicine to people who just
got the placebo
and you ask is the result from the real
medicine
much better than the result from the
placebo in order that
it is that there are no sort of hidden
cues that are given
you make the whole thing double-blind
that is the patients don't know
whether they're getting the placebo or
the real drug and the doctors giving the
the the tests don't know that it's all
sort of hidden away
and only after the results of you know
who got better who didn't get better
only after those results are known do
you kind of open the envelope
and say well this set of people were
actually given the real drug in this set
of people given the placebo
so that's kind of and people have felt
that that's sort of a
a gold standard for how to do medical
testing
of course like all these things it's a
good idea at some level and then it
falls apart
you know in modern times uh with partic
you know it becomes easier and easier to
tell was i really given the real drug or
was i given the placebo
there are all kinds of weird disasters
like the placebo ended up being
something
that was uh for whatever reason
you know was supposed to be an inert
substance that was just
found everywhere but actually some
population of people never usually got
that
and so the placebo actually had an
effect rather than just the medicine
um another thing that happens is
that the so those things can go wrong
the other thing that can happen is
a really quite significant effect is
completely lost because there's so much
diversity among the different people
taking these uh
these drugs that even though actually
everybody with you know
brown eyes and this and that and the
other and who's left-handed or something
would have done fantastically and it's
only the people who are right-handed
blue-eyed
who wouldn't have done well so to speak
but you never know that
because you mixed everything together um
and uh
you you know you did this test without
knowing all of the details of everybody
and
the fact is you'll never know all of the
details of everybody
um and and sort of teasing out
what's an important effect and what's
not is really difficult people talk
about
personalized medicine and trying to sort
of
use one's genetic information or other
things
to to sort of give one a special version
of each drug
that will be particular to you you you
in particular so to speak
but it's very hard to know how to apply
these statistical testing methods and so
on
in a case where everybody's sort of
getting something different so those are
some of the
kind of practical issues of the sort of
the scientific method i mean
another thing that ends up being
believed by people
from time to time is oh there's this
mechanism
of a little bit like the double-blind
medical experiments there's this
mechanism of peer review you know
somebody
writes a science paper and then it gets
sent off and
you know an anonymous group of peers
like kind of a jury
uh say oh yes this is good or this is
bad
well that system is
really doesn't work very well at all
because it's
often incredibly hard to tell whether
something is right or wrong
and usually people have all kinds of
prejudices and very often
people are gaming that system and saying
well gosh
if somebody cites my paper well then i
should accept their paper because then
i'll have another citation to my paper
and that's good for me and that's a more
important effect than whether the paper
that they're
that whether they're going to do the
really hard work to figure out is this
right or not and often you can't do
you can't figure out if it's right
because it was based on doing this
experiment on a rat
and you don't have that rat and you
can't redo the experiment
now there's there's a lot to be said
about kind of future reproducibility of
things like biomedical experiments
what's what's happening we've been very
involved in this
is making kind of automated labs where
you really can just specify
this is the series of steps you go
through it's not oh we wrote about it
it's paper
it's a piece of code that basically says
do this do this do this
you know run this you know heat this
thing up to this amount
stir it this way put it into this
machine do this do that
and then it becomes something where it's
much more possible to know oh you do
this experiment again
and you either get the same result or
you don't now there might be other
factors
that were important in whether you got
that result or didn't and that's
again comes back to this whole can you
do a sort of an independent scientific
experiment
and that's a that's a sort of key issue
with the scientific method can you
do an experiment where things are well
controlled enough
that you do the experiment a second time
you'll get the same answer
because not obvious you can do that if
the experiment involves a rat for
example
you will never get two rats in the exact
same state
with the exact same characteristics a
second time and so
different things will happen and then
you're thrown into this whole statistics
of whether they significantly different
or not significantly different
and so on so it's it's quite complicated
and i think
i think one thing that tends to happen
particularly in biomedical experiments
is people say we believe in double-blind
clinical trials we believe in
uh these kinds of you know scientific
peer review we believe in this that and
the other
and then they switch off the and let's
just think about what's going on
here i mean you know we've gone from a
time in antiquity
when people said everything that one can
know about the natural world one can
know by just
figuring it out by pure thought to
sometimes a point of view
we'll never know anything we'll never
figure anything out we just do this
experiment and we see whether where the
chips fall so to speak we see what
happens in the double-blind clinical
trial
well neither end of that story is
probably the right one
and it can often be the case although
people are
loath to do it in in biology often that
having some kind of theory is really
quite useful
if you see something it in in some
biological experiment it's like why does
you know when you give people vaccines
why do you get this cluster of side
effects
why are they that similar to things that
you get from the actual disease this
that and the other
well there's actually theories to be had
about this the theories might be right
they might be wrong
but just saying let's just do the
experiments that
the reason that's hard is
let's say take uh you know let's say
there's a
you know vaccine produces a little piece
of spike protein
real real situation the spike protein
goes to all different places all over
the body
gets carried there because gets into the
bloodstream goes to all kinds of places
you know attaches itself to heart muscle
attaches itself to
you know this or that thing and then has
an effect
okay if you say well let's try and uh
let's say it can go all over the body
and attach itself to different organs
does different kinds of things
that's a super diff difficult experiment
to pull together because you're seeing
oh it gave people a headache oh it gave
people some kind of heart infection
oh it gave people some other weird thing
it's so you know some
lung blood clot who knows what you know
lots of different kinds of things
it's being spread all over the place so
it's very it's very hard to pull that
together
as a define the experiment what are you
going to do it's something where you
kind of have to have a little bit of a
theory about what's going on
otherwise the data is so fragmented that
you'll never be able to pull it together
and see what what the core
effect is i mean it's sort of
and so if you say let's just look
through a peephole and look at this
particular
question you'll never see the big
picture so you need some level of theory
to see the big picture now you might
develop one theory
that might be complete nonsense but it's
still important to have a theory to
guide what what kinds of things you do
and let's say you have a theory
that might tell you oh there's 50
different experiments that you have to
do
that all might have some level of effect
and together they're really significant
even though on on their own each
individual one wouldn't show you very
much
i mean it sort of reminds me of of uh in
a quite different domain
um when you're like building a website
people say oh you should test your
website
by doing a b testing what is a b testing
a b
testing is you have two versions of the
website one where the button is green
one where the button is purple
and you say uh do people click on the
button more when it's green or when it's
purple
that's a is the button is green b is the
button is purple
which one is the winner and you can use
statistics to try and
answer that question once you have a
stream of thousands of people coming
through your website
well that's a fine idea but if you're
starting from
scratch from a blank website you say how
am i going to design this website
that is not realistic to answer by doing
a b testing
because you have to have a an overall
hypothesis my website is roughly going
to look like this
and i'm going to have a button once you
say i'm going to have a button that will
then
and i'm going to have it and it's going
to be one of three colors well then you
can start doing a b testing
to find out which color is best but when
it's sort of
you're still asking big picture
questions you can't really go in
and uh uh and look at sort of those
those micro details
and expect to actually come out with a
meaningful answer
so that was a long description of sort
of the the scientific method and i would
say
that a thing it always sounds good you
know in modern times probably
last 400 years or something saying it's
based on science
makes it sound really definitive and
good
but the thing to understand about
science is that
it's complicated business there are both
things where you can expect science to
make a prediction
and it can there are cases where science
from within the science itself
can tell you i'm sorry you will not be
able to make a definitive prediction
about this thing
there's just uh too much computational
irreducibility too much uncertainty
it's just there is not going to be a
definitive thing you can say like for
example the beginning of this pandemic
it was pretty obvious that a lot of
epidemiological questions
you needed a lot more data about how
people interacted with each other and so
on
to be able to answer questions about how
it mattered
a lot of details mattered that one
didn't know that affected
how much viruses would spread in this
place and that place and so on
i i think it's also in the case of this
pandemic has been a great example
of some pieces of science and
development of vaccines and so on very
spectacular
some other things it's like well gosh we
don't really know
and it's been i think it's very clear
that there are
issues about immunology issues about
virology and the way that
uh uh epidemics spread and so on that we
really
profoundly don't understand and where
there are probably some very basic
pieces of science
that eventually people will say oh my
gosh if they'd only known that back in
2020
they would have done this and this and
this what a shame they didn't know that
and people have the idea you know it's
science
that's doing it and we know everything
well we don't know everything about
science
and there's you know when things don't
make sense
they probably don't make sense even if
people are telling you
the science says this that or the other
because
usually often that you know when it
really doesn't make sense
um the uh um
it uh um it's um
uh you know i'm always suspicious of
things that don't make sense because
i've
my experience has been if it doesn't
seem to make sense it really doesn't
make sense
um and i think the thing that um
one has to realize is
for example when one does these
experiments and one says
you know a study shows blah blah blah
blah blah
well sometimes that's really right
sometimes it's very obvious
you know you plot the graph it's very
obvious that there's a you know hump
here a hump there
um you know it's it's um um uh but often
it's a more complicated story and uh
it's
it's sometimes um uh it's it can be um
it can be very challenging to figure out
what's going on and i think
you know having some kind of theory and
understanding why things are happening
the way they're happening
is a very useful guide to that plus also
you have to look at some of these
studies it's always a good exercise
um the uh um
it's always a bit good exercise we still
in these studies studies
say that left-handed people are better
at
um cricket than right-handed people
let's say
whatever who knows you have to say
really
you know what what went into that study
is it somehow obvious
or is that really telling one some new
information
or is it um uh oh you know i could um
i happen to be left-handed so there's a
pet peeve of mine that that um
if you have your mouse on the left-hand
side the the command-c command-v
characters uh that are often used for
you know copy paste and so on
are also on the left side so you can't
simultaneously use one hand for that
one hand for your mouse so somebody
might do a study that says
you know left-handed people are slower
at doing word processing than
right-handed people and it's like
and and therefore they say somebody
might might
take the implication so there's
something to do with brain processing
that is making left-handed people slower
to do
linguistic you know visual linguistic
tasks or something
well actually no you know it's just
because
the the keys are on different sides of
the keyboard the thing you thought you
were
studying in that study isn't the thing
you actually
got out of that study um
there was a point here made by pranav
asking double-blind randomized
controlled trial
yeah i should have i should have
mentioned one of the issues when you do
a
a double-blind trial is the question of
who gets
the uh you have to randomize who's going
to get
the drug versus who's going to get the
placebo it's got to be
just sort of randomly chosen and nobody
knows that until you open the envelope
sort of at the end of the trial
okay well that was a very long
description of uh
of of questions about about the
scientific method all right let's um
take a look at um some of the
questions that have come in here there's
a question from motu
what caused the split between the
evolutionary parts of plant life and
animal life
i don't know the answer to that i will
make the comment
that there are it used to be thought
that there were just these
um two big kingdoms
of living organisms animals and plants
you know plants have things like
chloroplasts and they have cellulose
cell walls kind of rigid cell walls
animals have
have sort of flexible floppy cell walls
and so on and and there are other
plenty of other differences then it
became clear that there were actually
other kingdoms of life
first the archaea and then i think just
recently there have been some claims
that there are other
sort of fundamentally different forms of
life that work in different ways
and for example these different kingdoms
can
have different ways in which the genetic
code is used to make proteins and things
um and that's that's sort of a
distinguishing feature
what caused some of these kingdoms to
win out
over others i don't think we know at all
i mean the question of
you know could the archaea have been the
dominant kingdom of life
that led to uh sort of the full
sort of evolutionary uh development
um i'm sure the answer is yes i think
one of the things that one learns from
from looking at biology and evolution
and so on is
uh once you have certain raw material
there are always ways to assemble that
raw material
to achieve some particular thing so for
example
uh once in a sense it's like computers
once you have a universal computer you
can program it to do anything
once you have a living organism that can
make sort of arbitrary proteins and
things like this specified by its
genetic
program effectively then in a sense it's
possible to make that organism do almost
anything
now you may not be able to get there
from here there may not be a historical
path
that allows you to grow wheels let's say
that has a sort of way to get from
walking to having wheels
there may not be a way to go sort of
organism to organism
you're getting a little bit of a wheel
and then more of a wheel and more of a
wheel and eventually you're purely
dealing with wheels
um so that can be an issue and there are
but it's it's remarkable the extent to
which
given the sort of building blocks of
life you can achieve all sorts of
different things
so for example let's take plants versus
animals there are fundamentally
different forms of growth for plants and
animals
in plants because the cells tend to be
rigid they have cellulose cell walls
once you've put down a cell you're stuck
with it
you don't get to sort of squash it and
and deform it and so on whereas in an
animal
the cells are flexible so even if you
put down that cell
early in the development of the animal
eventually as more cells get put down it
can be
squashed and deformed and so on so
plants for example
very often use the idea of branching
they make
more pieces of themselves by you know
they have a stem and then they branch
and the stems branch
and so on and that's something you can
always do you can make up
lots of different shapes by different
forms of branching
even though you never have to go back
you never have to deform what was there
before
whereas animals have different ways of
growing where often they can build up
sort of forces
that cause things deform and fold over
and things like that
which plants can't do but you know does
it fundamentally lead
to a different uh i don't know quality
of life for something well i think
that's hard to tell
and i don't think it's obvious that that
just because you have cellulose cell
walls means you fundamentally can't
do this or that i mean it's not the case
you know you have plenty of insect
eating plants that can you know move and
so on even though
generally plants are pretty stationary
but
um the question of of uh
of what led maybe maybe there's more
that's known about what led to sort of a
divergence
of different uh uh general approaches to
life
um early on uh i think the other thing
that tends to happen is
it's very much like in technology once
you've got
a thing like cellular cell walls then
you build a lot of stuff based on that
you once you have this rigid structure
well then you can build giant tree
trunks and
build up these tall things and use the
fact that you know you can be the
tallest tree in the forest and get more
light and
this that and the other um and uh you
know once you have certain
apparatus certain tools you then get to
build lots of things on the base of
those tools and then it becomes much
more difficult
for some other tool set effectively to
compete
and say well actually we're going to
make something that is
uh where i don't know what um you know
invent some other
form of life that's very different from
uh from the way plants or animals work
um it tends to be the case once there's
enough level of sort of
evolutionary development that it becomes
difficult to compete with that
even if you had a better mousetrap so to
speak even if you had a better scheme i
mean
there are many examples of uh cases
with us humans for example where people
might say from the outside that's a
really bad
piece of biological design like a famous
one is in our eyes
the the retina of our eyes that where
the photoreceptor cells
there are a bunch of cross connections
in front of where the light receptors
are
so there are a bunch of things which
which help us detect edges and things
like that in visual scenes
where you would say the right design is
to have all that circuitry behind
where the light is coming in and hitting
photoreceptors and in some organisms
that i think crabs do it the other way
king crabs and things do it the other
way around
that evolved eyes separately they do
have it that other way around
but we are stuck with it the way around
that we have it
and in a sense some other organism could
come along and say i flipped it around
but we've got so much else in a sense
going for us by now at this point in
evolution
that that you know that if that sort of
fundamentally rethinking that
is is something that doesn't uh end up
being competitively sensible
um there's a question here why haven't
animals evolved with the same size as
dinosaurs
uh for example brontosaurus was a was a
massive creature
there's a lot that's been studied about
the um
the value of being big versus not being
big
one of the things that happens if you're
big certain things scale in certain ways
like for example if you're going to be a
certain weight and certain a
certain height and so on your bones
better be a certain thickness in order
to support that weight
another thing would be if you're going
to be really big does that mean you need
a bigger brain
or does that mean well actually you can
get by with a small brain or maybe some
extra sort of brainlet
ganglia you know other parts of the body
and so on
or if you're you know if you're really
big maybe it takes a really long time
for the nerve impulse to go from your
for your brain where you see that
predator coming to the time when you
flip your tail around
to uh to do this or that thing because
you're so long that just that nerve
impulse takes a long time to to get
through you so to speak
but so there are different things that
happen as you sort of scale an animal up
or down there's a whole
field of so-called allometry that is
this whole question of
when you when you rescale animals and
things how do you have to rescale
different parts of the animal how do
different
different pieces rescale how do they how
do they rescale
as as the animal grows which part of the
animal grows first and so on
um the uh um
and what uh you know how how does that
how does that
um uh you know if you're going to be a
tree of a certain height
how thick should your trunk be in order
to support that tree
all those kinds of things so there's a
lot of kind of scaling of that type
it also tends to be the case that there
are many fewer of bigger animals in a
given ecosystem
given a certain amount of food if there
are if everything was a if there were
gazillions of big animals they eat up
all this food
very quickly whereas if there are lots
of small animals
they tend to eat it less that they'll
they'll they'll be able to be many more
small animals than there will be big
ones so it tends to be the case
that there are of any given species like
for example
the total number of i don't know
cockroaches in the world is much much
larger than the total number
of uh i don't know um uh
you know deer or something some some big
animal
um and that that's a very typical thing
that's seen throughout the fossil record
the number of of big animals is much
smaller than the number
the number of individuals in the species
of big animals
is smaller than the number of
individuals in a species of small
animals
also a different effect the number of
species of small animals tends to be
larger
than the number of species of big
animals there are many there are not
that many mammals
that exist whereas there are gazillions
there are millions of
beetle species that exist um
and i'm not sure how well understood
that phenomenon
is of why there are more species why
there are more individuals of a given
species
when the when the individuals are
smaller that's reasonably well
understood
in terms of well you've got a fixed food
supply how many organisms can you
support and so on
but i think uh and the question of why
there's sort of nothing that's evolved i
mean i think you know blue whales do
you know they're competitive with
dinosaurs they're not they're not as
impressive as dinosaurs but they're sort
of competitive
why is there not a mega mega whale that
is
you know vastly larger and the size of
you know
three city blocks or something um most
likely part of the reason is
there are pure mechanical things like
bone has a certain strength
and you've got to invent a new kind of
bone if you're going to have the the
animal be a lot bigger than that because
otherwise you can't support you know you
can't keep the animal rigid with it with
bone of the type of thing that bone
already is
so i think those are my some guesses in
terms of
of why um you know an interesting
question if you look at the fossil
record
there are times when the total number of
species seems to be larger
smaller et cetera there have been a
bunch of extinction events
half a dozen or so big extinction events
in the history of life on earth
like the one at the end of the the 65
million years ago
at the end of the cretaceous period
produced by this asteroid impact
the kt boundary um that uh
uh was probably the sort of the end of
the dinosaurs
um there'd been you know a bunch of
those extinction events and they will
uh they will get rid of you know 60 of
all species that exist at a given time
or something
um but if you just look at the total
number of species that existed through
time
it's kind of gone up and down and i
don't think that there's anything
notably
different for example between dinosaur
times and our time so don't think
there's an explanation
about oh there are many more species and
that's why there aren't such big ones or
something like that
i think it may be uh uh it may just be
the
the coincidence of the way that this
sort of the tower of evolution has
has gone so i don't i'm not sure i have
a a um
uh a great answer to that okay maybe one
or two more
questions than i have to run off here uh
moist is asking um
[Music]
oh well this is more a life and times
question
saying there are only 12 but the
question is how do you deal with
detractors
um and how do you deal with
uh uh what do you do when people
say negative things and are critical
about what you're doing
you know i think for me in particular
the basic thing is i do the things i do
because i like doing it
i like doing those things and that's the
thing i care most about
and i care about am i doing the things i
want to do
and am i satisfied for myself with the
things that i'm doing
there's a whole separate question which
is do other people give me positive
feedback about the things i'm doing
or do they say oh i think the things
you're doing are totally crazy
or you know what you're doing is
absolutely terrible et cetera et cetera
et cetera
i think that um i have tended and maybe
it's
it's a um uh uh
i've tended to be very much focused on
am i satisfied with what i'm doing
i have a certain sort of code of what i
think
represents a good a right a
useful project and that's what i care
the most about
what i've noticed is when there's a
project that i do
that is something that is really going
to perhaps move the world forward in any
in some significant way
it's pretty much guaranteed that people
will say
a lot of people will say that's a crazy
project that couldn't possibly work
you know you shouldn't do that project
it'll have all kinds of consequences
blah blah blah
and this is just the way the world is
set up because
most of the time the world is a fairly
predictable place
where sort of people are doing what they
had planned to do and sort of everything
is moving forward in a
in a in a sort of very fairly uniform
way and that's a good thing
if it wasn't for that you know we'd be
spending all of our time and
at different times in history in
different places in the world this is
what happens
is you're spending all of your time
worrying about oh my gosh what could
happen tomorrow
it could just turn my life upside down
the fact that that isn't what's
happening most of the time in the in the
western world these days most of the
time
is is as far as i'm concerned for my
particular
uh kinds of things that i like to do is
a good thing
you can just sort of assume that
everything's going to just keep going in
in in the same way it has been going
and that means that for people where if
you say i'm going to come and i'm going
to do something incredibly new and
different
many people are going to say er you know
what we're happy with the way things are
going
just don't do that that's that's
irrelevant something we don't want
and so if you think well actually
on the other side of the hill if we go
to all this work on the other side of
the hill we're going to get to something
better
well if you think that and you're you
know
then then it's something then the way
that you actually do that
is to be interested in doing it for
yourself because other people are going
to tell you don't try and climb that
hill
it's not going to work it's a bad idea
etc etc cetera
and i think that's a uh you know i think
that the the important thing as far as
i'm concerned
is to be mostly have your own sort of
value system about what you think is
worth doing and what you
like to do and so on and just just do it
now
you know the world gives useful feedback
sometimes
of uh about things you're doing but you
have to kind of
pay attention to it in a very filtered
way i mean
like uh for example i don't know these
these live streams that i'm doing you
know i started off doing them year and a
half ago
people seemed to like them i kept doing
them i had fun doing them
uh so you know it's a it's a good thing
i'm gonna do it if people
if it was the case that uh you know
nobody seemed to care at all and and i
was like
oh my gosh i don't really want to do
this then i would have stopped doing
them
but it's something where there's a
you know have i read reviews of these
live streams i don't even know if there
are any
um no i never have um and
and actually i i'm not sure i would you
know i don't know what i would take from
that
maybe if there was some particular
suggestion uh you know
um uh you know about
about it i might uh find that useful but
otherwise it's like oh this is a bad
idea because whatever
it's like well i probably i don't know
it doesn't doesn't make much difference
so i think the um
sometimes i think if there are people
criticizing what you're doing
it's actually a good sign because it's a
sign that you're doing something that
isn't
just same old same old what people
expect to be done
i mean sometimes there are other effects
like you know
if you are successful at what you're
doing people will say
oh my gosh you know there has to be
something wrong that person is being
successful
actually it's it's it tends to go in two
different groups
there are like hey it's cool to see
something that's successful
you know i i like that let me let me see
more of that because it's fun to
to kind of watch something that's
successful that's that's one point of
view the other point of view is
oh my gosh you know i should have been
doing that instead of this person
you know i'm really i really should be
there not them type thing
and uh or or just oh if they're
successful there must be something
terrible about what's going on
um i think uh sometimes sometimes people
can hold
uh well it's it's some uh so it kind of
goes both ways and i think
that um from my point of view insofar as
i've done lots of successful projects
um i find it really nice that um
we've been able to involve a bunch of
people particularly in more recent times
as we've been doing
all kinds of live streaming and things
like that involve people
in kind of seeing the process of doing
these projects
because i think it's a it's a very
uplifting thing
to see successful projects on the other
hand you can take the point of view
oh you know it's like uh
people might say you know
uh you know well i was kind of vaguely
thinking about doing that too
you know and and how come this person
got to do it and i didn't get to do it
well
you know maybe i mean there are plenty
of things where i've
thought of doing something but i haven't
actually done it
and somebody else will do it or some
other company will do it or something
like this
and i'm like oh i could have done that
they did it it's like that's the way it
works
you know in in um one can't do
everything and
the only question is whether the things
one picks to do oneself
are the things that are the best things
to want to pick to do oneself
or whether one is picking oh i'm doing
the the grunt stuff that's really
horrible i don't really like doing it
and those other guys over there they're
getting all the fun if
if that's the situation then you're
probably picking the wrong things to do
but uh anyway that that's um uh that
would be my
now in terms of the you know the the
more of the kid level of this
i would say that um uh
the dynamics unfortunately it's a long
time since i was 12 years old
but um trying to uh and of course for me
it's kind of interesting to see because
all the kids i
you know the kids i knew when i was 12
years old they're now you know they've
had all
you know they've had careers or whatever
else happened to them and so you kind of
know the end of the story and those kids
who are like
i'm going to do great things you know
etc etc etc
some of them did some of them didn't
sometimes you can kind of see that
pattern
and you can say well i knew why that was
going to happen i knew this was going to
happen i
because i've been interested in people
kind of my whole life i
i certainly uh both explicitly and
implicitly made all kinds of predictions
talk about the scientific method so to
speak i made all kinds of predictions
about what was going to happen to the
people i knew when i was actually
specifically
12 years old and you know some of them
were right some of them were wrong
the ones that were both right and wrong
but they've been sort of interesting to
see
why did i make that mistake uh what was
the thing that i correctly saw
that turned out to be something that uh
that eventually
sort of uh became a big success or a big
problem
etc um but i think uh
in terms of um um you know the most
important
thing somehow at least in my way of
doing things is to have a
a sense of what it is that you actually
like what it is that you like doing
what is that you like having achieved
and so on and
in the end sometimes i mean sometimes
what people like achieving is external
measures of achievement
like did you win that competition did
you get that
uh you know scholarship did you do
whatever sometimes
the thing that people like is that
external sense of achievement
i haven't ever been that interested in
that uh for whatever reason of egotism
or otherwise
i'd be more interested in you know
this thing that i've done this project
that i've done am i satisfied with it
rather than is the world giving me
positive feedback about it
and i think it's also uh the question of
of um you know i think the dynamics with
them
with everybody is is kind of like oh
there are people who
like you they're people who won't like
you they're people where
uh somehow you know in
in um uh there's you know it's it's
uh probably more pleasant to hang out
with people who like you usually
on the other hand for me when there are
people who've like i think what you've
done is totally crazy and
you know etc etc etc actually it's
pretty interesting for me to talk to
those people now sometimes
those people are just just far off the
deep end
but sometimes it's like you know i think
this thing you're doing is
doesn't make sense because blah blah
blah blah and you can have a discussion
with them
and sometimes you say oh that's actually
interesting that's a good
point you know i hadn't thought of that
that's uh
a reasonable objection you know maybe i
get around in this way maybe i get
around it that way
maybe you're right that this is a bad
idea um and sometimes if
the person you're talking to is
reasonable and is prepared to have the
the discussion it's like um uh
you know oh okay now i understand that
makes sense
or you know this thing that i thought
was the most terrible thing
now that i understand it it's like oh
okay
you know that makes sense um now you
know you also get into situations where
people
and hopefully not by age 12 although i
have no idea in modern times um
the uh where people are just so sure
about something
that anything you say is never gonna
change their mind
they're so sure about this piece of i
don't know
you know i don't know politics
religion this that the other um you know
that they're just
absolutely certain or science for that
matter they're absolutely certain this
is the way it works
you say well is there really evidence
for that oh
you know like like for example it's
usually a giveaway
when somebody says and i even noticed
this for my
for myself i have to admit this that
when i'm trying to make an argument for
something
and i start saying oh i've been working
on this for
30 years and so i know what i'm talking
about that's a
a dead giveaway that i don't know what
i'm talking about
it's a you know it's a it's a dead
giveaway that i can't really
explain i'm just having to appeal to
i'm sure i do know the explanation but i
can't come up with it right now
and you know i've been thinking about
this for such a long time i must be able
to explain it
but well actually i can't and and that's
a bad sign
so i think that that um uh that that
tends to be you know when
when people uh you know they're people
who will be very closed
to uh talking about something and and
usually
if you really kind of pick away at it
it's like they don't really know why
they think this that or the other thing
but they just they've thought it for so
long
and maybe they they think i've thought
this for so long i must have had a good
reason for thinking that
and for example recently i've been
working on foundations of mathematics
and trying to understand some things
about that and i'm pretty sure
that some things that i believe for a
long time about that aren't really right
um and uh that's a in a sense one has to
have a certain degree of personal
confidence
to get to the point where you can say
well i have believed this for a long
time
but the evidence is now coming in that
it isn't true
and so i'm actually going to change my
mind i think it's one of the things
when one uh you know i kind of um
uh aspire to in a sense is
even if i'm really quite certain about
something if somebody brings me real
evidence that i'm wrong
that i can actually change my mind and
certainly i've seen in
for example business leaders
intellectual leaders that's an attribute
that i've
that i've uh often seen among the most
successful such
people is the ability to change their
mind when confronted with actually good
evidence i mean not just to sort of
flap in the wind when every new thing
comes in they just change what they're
saying
but you know even if they've really
believed for a long time
this is the way it is some new evidence
comes in that they can actually change
their mind
um and uh you know i think that's a um
uh
that's something i i would i would hope
that
i mean i i do interact with some some uh
folks in the 12 year old ish set um
and uh uh it's interesting the extent to
which even at that age it seems that
people in modern times maybe it's always
been this way
are very very certain about certain
kinds of things uh i mean it's kind of
like
like um you know at times people might
have said i read it in a book
so it must be true i saw it on tv so it
must be true
uh you know i was told it by a teacher
so it must be true i was um
you know this person who i think is cool
said it so it must be true type thing
you know i i i'm a great believer in
in um uh somehow the thing to
to learn in a sense is how to determine
for yourself whether the thing is true
and how to get confidence about
whether it's true just because everybody
says this or that thing
doesn't necessarily mean it's true it
also doesn't necessarily mean it's false
i mean there are things that i have that
are sort of conventional wisdom
um that i mostly in past
years have said i don't believe in this
conventional wisdom
you know i'm going to do something
different and sometimes i was wrong
and the conventional wisdom was
perfectly correct and there was
something i hadn't realized about the
conventional wisdom
and that was just not part of
the thought process that i'd gone
through and uh
then you know that's one of those change
your mind type moments when you realize
that
but often it's like can you actually
justify what you're doing for yourself
as opposed to just saying well uh
you know can you give the argument sort
of all the way down so to speak or not
um anyway i don't think that necessarily
um
it's it's some uh
i'm not sure that deals with the the the
um the detractors for the 12 year old
set and i'm not sure that i'm
necessarily um too well equipped to
address that
beyond i suppose saying that um uh
you know i think one tends to be happy
if the person one is most interested in
uh sort of convincing about what one's
doing is oneself
and not other people because other
people you don't have
uh you have a lot more control about
about of yourself
than you do of of uh what other people
think or say or do or whatever
all right that was a that was a a
digression in a quite different
direction
um all right i think we should probably
uh um
oh gosh there's a lot of interesting
questions you guys always come up with
interesting questions
um but i think we should probably
wrap it up uh for today here
slightly uh unusual set of topics for
the day
um but uh i all interesting
and thank you for those questions and um
uh thanks for joining us and um hope to
see you again next week